it takes a cool head and an eye for
opportunity to find a way out of
long-term unemployment but artist nikola
abusa has them and has turned the lost
industry of charwa a grim belgian city
with 25 out of work to good
use they're gonna start to raise
everything but for me it's like
adventure park nicolas started
organizing tours of unlikely tourist
spots it's not full employment but it's
a start imaginative and riddled with
dark belgian humor he understands the
key is timely microfinance and mobility
how have people adapted to
this massive unemployment
but
there is something we call that a car
then belgium is small then people uh
they work they work somewhere else you
know easier for some than others
christopher koviles is 24 and has spent
the past five years hunting work after
his employers steel smelters here
couldn't offer a contract when the
recession started in 2008
europe just back from recess is
addressing the jobs crisis with a new
program being considered by meps to
connect three hitherto separate jobs
innovation and microfinance programs
it'll help workers get any of 1.4
million vacancies across the eu
the key says a unit head at the european
employment service is mobility we will
get the necessary financial means
in order to support the workers in the
european union
who are willing
to search for a job in another member
states foreign
costing 815 million euros between 2014
and 2020 will also help promote
activities that foster employment in
europe's jobless hotspots